¡Muy buenos días a todos! Hoy os vamos
hablar de un tema fascinante. Imaginad
que dividiésemos las reservas de
petróleo de cada país por su número
de habitantes. En lugar de renta per
cápita obtendríamos algo así como
petróleo por persona. ¿Cuál diríais que es
el país con el indicador más alto
probablemente alguno estéis pensando en Arabia Saudita, en Emiratos (EAU) o en Kuwait…
¡Pues no! La respuesta es Groenlandia. Groenlandia tiene casi tanto
petróleo como Rusia pero tan sólo la
población de Ávila. Y os preguntaréis,
¿siendo así, por qué no es el país más
rico del mundo? Ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver.
¿Alguna vez te has planteado cómo es la
vida en lo que algunos consideran una
utopía? Una utopía donde no existe la
propiedad privada, donde la gente
mantenga sus tradiciones milenarias
donde todos vivamos en una especie de
tribu. Si quieres puedes probarlo, no
tienes más que hacer las maletas, cogerlas
y mudarte a Nuuk, la capital de
Groenlandia.
¡Efectivamente! El país de los esquimales.
En realidad el término más correcto
sería inuit, al parecer la palabra
esquimal no les hace mucha gracia. El
pueblo inuit ha sido capaz de mantener
su modo de vida intacto durante el paso de los siglos.
Por supuesto, si en algún momento
durante este viaje, durante esta aventura
echas de menos el confort occidental, no
te preocupes, en Groenlandia encontrarás
supermercados donde poder encontrar
prácticamente cualquier cosa.
Además también hay edificios tan
impresionantes como este centro cultural
que estamos viendo en la foto.
Y os preguntaréis,  ¿quién paga todo esto? Lo
paga Dinamarca. Groenlandia es un estado
libre asociado del gobierno danés.
Eso significa que para casi todos los
efectos son independientes: tienen su
propia policía, sus propios colegios
donde por supuesto se enseña el idioma inuit y tiene sus propias leyes, sus
propios impuestos menos en lo referente
al ejército y política exterior.
En eso todo les viene dado de Dinamarca. A cambio los daneses subvencionan todos
lo subvencionable: colegios, libros tiendas de ultramarinos, supermercados todo todo
lo que es podéis imaginar está pagado
desde Copenhague.
Los daneses, por su parte, lo que reciben
es un territorio enorme sobre el que
colocar factorías de pescado, mucho del
pescado del bacalao que comemos en
Europa está pescado por barcos daneses
y procesado en Groenlandia y, por
supuesto también, montan sus bases
militares. Por ejemplo la base aérea de Thule de
la que hemos oído hablar muchas veces en películas, videojuegos, etcétera… Eso
esta en Groenlandia. La economía
groenlandesa, por otro lado, no es que sea
nada del otro mundo
son 60 mil habitantes, la mitad se dedica
a la pesca
tradicional y la otra mitad se dedica a
ser funcionarios y a gestionar ese
dinero que les llega de Dinamarca que es con lo que realmente viven. Sin embargo los
groenlandeses siempre han sido muy
nacionalistas, siempre han pedido más
independencia al gobierno de Dinamarca.
Los daneses, por su parte, tampoco les han puesto ninguna pega porque, a fin de
cuentas, para ellos Groenlandia no es
más que una fuente de problemas. Se ve
muy bien en la serie de televisión Borgen
que habla de política danesa, es una
serie danesa en la que podemos ver la
opinión de la sociedad, la opinión de
los políticos al respecto
Que bueno, consideran que
Groenlandia es un territorio con el que no
saben muy bien qué hacer.
Pero ahora, Fonseca, las cosas parecen
estar cambiando. En los últimos años se
ha descubierto que Groenlandia tiene petróleo
Mucho petróleo
Pero, no sólo hablamos de oro negro, también tienen todo tipo de minerales, uranio
hierro, cinc, diamantes…
Tan sólo en gas natural se estima que
Groenlandia tiene la tercera parte
del gas que aún queda por descubrir en
el mundo. ¡Una tercera parte de todo el
gas que se estima descubrir en todo el mundo.
Respecto al petróleo convencional hablamos
del 10%. Es más o menos las mismas reservas
que tiene Rusia y todo esto, repito, en un
país con menos de 60 mil habitantes.
En otras palabras, casi podemos decir
que a los inuit les ha tocado la
lotería, ¿no te parece?
Sí,  Couto, pero no todo es
tan fantástico como parece porque es
cierto que Groenlandia tiene unos
recursos naturales envidiables, pero
también tienen una capa de hielo
cubriendo toda la isla que en algunos
puntos es de más de 1 km de
grosor
Claro, hacer una mina en España puede ser más fácil o más difícil pero en
esencia es hacer un agujero en el suelo.
En Groenlandia primero tienes que
atravesar, que perforar, una capa de hielo
de más de un kilómetro de grosor, lo
cual hace que sea mucho más caro
extraer cualquier mineral. No hablemos
ya del petróleo... Casi todo el
petróleo groenlandés está en la
costa, en la zona marítima y lo tiene
que explotar con barcos. Barcos que se
ponen muy cerquita de la costa.
En la costa groenlandesa están cayendo
constantemente bloques de hielo que son
los famosos icebergs. ¡El iceberg que
hundió el Titanic venía de Groenlandia!
Tú imagínate que estás con tu barquito
petrolero extrayendo tu crudo y te
cae de repente un bloque de hielo del
tamaño de las torres Kio
A mí no me gustaría estar ahí. Eso
además de arriesgado es caro, hace que
el barril de crudo en Groenlandia sea
mucho más caro que
el barril de crudo en Arabia Saudí.  A
esto hay que sumarle el hecho de que en
Groenlandia no hay carreteras. ¡No hay
carreteras! Con lo cual los minerales o
los recursos que extraigas solamente
los puedes transportar o bien por barco,
o bien por avión. Eso encarece
muchísimo los costes, y ya por encima de
todo, está el caos legislativo
groenlandés. En Groenlandia
por no haber no hay siquiera
propiedad privada, con lo cual las
empresas se lo piensan dos veces antes
de acercarse a la isla a explotar los recursos
Esto podría explicar por qué
muchas inversiones se han parado los
últimos dos años
No es extraño que ello coincida con la
baja en los precios del petróleo: como
es tan caro explotar los recursos de
Groenlandia, el beneficio desaparece
cuando hay que vender a precios tan
reducidos.
Eso también explicaría por qué el
nuevo presidente groenlandés, que lleva
alrededor de dos años en el gobierno, ha
dejado a un lado el tema de la
independencia porque se ha dado cuenta
de que Groenlandia necesita de Dinamarca
y de sus subvenciones para seguir
sobreviviendo.
Groenlandia es un país desconocido para casi todo el mundo, pero tiene un potencial de crecimiento
inmenso. Hoy ya no pueden explotar sus recursos naturales
pero el día en que lo hagan van a
llenar las páginas de los periódicos.
Además es un tema muy interesante
porque es uno de los pocos territorios
vírgenes que aún quedan en el mundo.
Desde VisualPolitik lo vamos a seguir
muy de cerca, no sólo lo concerniente a
Groenlandia sino a toda la política del
Ártico que cada vez es más importante.
Si tenéis alguna duda o queréis
aportar algo, dejad un comentario
Muchas gracias y hasta otro día